ウズ
今から日本語の講座を行います
おやまもとさん旅行どうだったいやぁ楽しかったよ
あお土産買ってきたおありがとうやつまんないもので悪いね
いやいや素晴らしいモンドありがとういやーよかったよふみかクリアーブルーでね
もう
者らしい感じさせないよあ奥さん元気にしてる
元気元気この前はたしたケーキは気に入ってくれたのかな
全部食べたよ大学時代にそのケーキが好きだと教えてくれて再見積もりはどうなってる
か
あれは人たちにしたんだ一番安くて良いものを作ってくれる人たちかいいね
でいつ来るあそっか今日の賛辞だったんだあ
ジャン損じなったらお茶を出してくれますか温かいものがいいですかそれとも冷たい
ものがいいですかどっちでもいいですよ
かしこまりましたみんなおはよう所長おはようございます社長おはようございます
ユーバーとの打ち合わせのことなんだけどキャンツールになったからみんなで飲みに
行かない
ぜひ来ます僕も行きます
あ山本さん前のせいで先週みんな残業したや
あんたのこと嫌いだけど一緒に働いてるから仕方なくこれを買ってきたよ
お待た安っぽ予選で買うっていうか俺こういうのを加え4
じゃあ今度は2000円のものを買ってね専用のものにする英語が話せるようになり
たい
俺もあっ久美子は元気
お願いだからやめて大学時代には猫のちょっと付き合っていったこと言ったっけ
毎週行ってる1回ラブホ行った時にないっちゃいちゃったり仕事の話をしよう
日立にしたんだ一番安くていい物をつくってくれないけどまぁ昔から付き合ってるから
ね
だよな結果いつもそこにしてるからもう相見積もりなんか要らなくね
アーちゃんさん次男たらお茶を出せそれ
何で私がやんなきゃいけないな女だからこのフェイスで一番働いてるし
僕ボスだから遅刻していいんだそう真面目に仕事しなきゃ
所長今日もタバコ臭いですよ昨日繋が党と離婚届を出したんだ
今日は一緒に選んでくれギターの練習できなくなっちゃう自身の方がもしです
me